hey guys at IKEA with arattai who's
going to walk me a division noob through
recalibration yeah so recalibration is
something you unlock in the tech wing
and it's really cool it's like further
pushing your armor to a style that you
want to have it and kind of playing on
those RPG elements which is like really
cool so in layman's terms this is just a
way for you to put on mods to your armor
and gear to just make you better but
also to make to basically designate what
kind of class you want to play and
helping you with the stats that you need
to play that class yeah Yuki there was
no classes in this game exactly I you
can argue that there's sort of classes
but not really just appending on how you
play but um yeah it's it basically lets
you roll off a certain stat or you know
like something that you didn't like on a
piece of armor to something you do want
and that's you know again just like you
said it's so you can play a certain way
or really min/max something like pulse
duration or pulse damage etc or turret
duration you know like I love turrets so
I wanna you know make a really tanky
long-lasting turret so you could do that
if you wanted to that's what
recalibrating lets you do also it helps
you balance out your gear the pricing on
the recalibrations will ramp as you
either get or don't get what you want
right so I have a lot of credits so I'll
just do this as an example yeah you're
like okay this is pretty good but you
know I want to get a no pulse duration
right got it so I'm like okay I'm gonna
roll this I didn't get pulse duration I
get what you wanted which you know it
sucks right so yeah you're like okay I'm
late the slot machine right how many
Fenix bucks was that that that wasn't a
high end fortunately this is just a
superior purple yeah and that just cost
normal dollar I was not about to roll
you weren't gonna do the Phoenix yeah I
gotta save those I'm poor they also nerf
the Phoenix credit drops in the dark
zone so I can't I can't be doing that
but you know I just want to show you how
much more expensive it is right so that
first one was 16,000 yes this is 22
hours discredits yeah regular excited
but you're like I am stubborn I really
want it yeah I have
money for it so I'm gonna try again and
I still didn't uh cuz this one's really
hard to get right because there's so
many more attributes that you could end
up rolling in this case because this is
the one that has you know like it's
really just different things that just
went up to 49 yeah from 28 so I think
with Phoenix credits for high-end I
think it's like 31 then like a 48 and
then it gets like it just keeps going up
and up so it can be really frustrating
or you could get really lucky it's just
like you play it do you pray rather too
rng this is what a lot of people have a
slot machine yeah exactly so but this is
this is where you can you know really
min/max hopefully you guys are getting
lucky with your roles cuz clearly I
didn't get lucky but you know that's
part of the game I feel like that's part
of what has giving it replayability is
because you're not always gonna get
lucky and you're gonna have to you know
hold that slot machine in this but yeah
with Frick risk comes great reward right